your phone is so distracting isn't
it your phone distracts you all day long
it's just a huge
distraction well you know what we don't
want to blame your phone I guess it's
the apps in your phone these apps are so
distracting the games and the news feeds
and the social
media all
I know I know some people that
waste
hours hours playing little games on
their
phone games that are built and designed
to release dopamine and keep you
playing and the games and the
engineers that's their
focus same thing with the
newsfeed right what what are the news
what are the news feed doing constantly
updating information on the big story
new big
story that you need to stay up to date
on it's the big thing that's happening
you don't want to miss
it the news so
distracting doesn't even seem like they
should be allowed to run so many stories
because it's distracting you and those
game Engineers shouldn't be able to
design those games because they're
distracting ing you maybe they should be
illegal and of course there's social
media there's Twitter there's the gram
there's the Facebook e and Snapchat and
Tick
Tock all 100% designed to lure you in
and then keep you trapped in their
little
algorithm
so those are some
forces of distraction that we have to
contend
with powerful forces by the way designed
by brilliant people that are
making millions billions of dollars to
keep you distracted that's their sole
goal is keeping you focused on that
screen and not on your life can you
believe that they do that to
you can you believe
it well guess
what it's not the fault of the the games
or the
news or the social media platforms and
the
algorithms it's not their
fault there's only one person to blame
and that's you they cannot make you look
at their junk at their feed but you do
it
voluntarily you click and scroll and
look and get that little dopamine hit
that they don't roll out to you over and
over again and you snort it up like an
addict and we're trying to blame them
are they to blame for that are they are
they to blame for our actions I actually
say
no we are to blame I am to blame we give
them control when we click and scroll we
give up our time and our thoughts and
our
freedom but we don't have to do
that we do not have to accept this we
don't have to bow down to these dopamine
dealers these thought thieves these mind
murderers we don't have to accept
it get
control free your mind stop scrolling
stop
clicking and start living